so Gary we view you as one of the best
of terms of balancing creativity with
social media because you seem to be very
skilled at doing both at the same time
curious do you have tweetdeck on while
you're rendering up to how are you how
are you able to do that it's a real art
because social media can be a real time
suck sorry to my word but it can be and
it can really kind of draw you into you
know tweeting about stuff that's not
relevant but it's connecting people but
then you're also able to turn out
excellent work so how do you balance
that again that's very kind of you i
mean i i'm sure out in the world there's
people that unfollowed me because I
probably tweeted too much or tweet too
much about something and I think that's
the main thing it's one of the main
things for me as I can't be concerned
about you know how many followers are I
have you know and are they gonna
unfollow me if I say the wrong thing
it's just being yourself as they always
say and just talking about not only your
projects but trying to support other
people and ty meant so many other people
on online through social media because
of that and the balance i think is i'm
lucky that they basically you know my
day job is directing its editing it's
you know doing something within the
industry so i have time you know and
with the iphone you know like you can be
anywhere and actually tweet like people
think like oh my god they don't have a
life while they're doing is tweeting is
like like you said you can be rendering
and you can send it
I mean there's multitasked I mean I have
like three computers running at times
and my laptop my imac something else is
rendering and there's there's time if
you want to make it but then the the
flip side is if you devote too much to
it then you're actually yours you're
seen as well that's all they're doing so
there's a there's a fine balance and
again I don't think I'm you know I model
myself off other people that I like
seeing what they talk about and how they
do it as well so it's not it's not think
I'm the leader up but I just kind of
pick and choose the best of how I see
others do it do you find yourself very
disciplined in terms of your time
management and see you having a list of
to do you know I kind of do it sometimes
a mental one sometimes it's one in my
iphone you know and it's a tough balance
because I actually am trying to write
and social media canos burying me
sometimes and not by choice it's kind of
like you're addicted to like well what's
what are they up to what is this person
up to lure you know and it's kind of I
have friends that our writers they put
themselves in twitter jail they say and
it's it's something that I want to do
but it's it's one of those things I
can't and that's bad and and I've fallen
behind on the writing because of that
and I'm on pace but it's something we're
consistently I have to have people tell
me you know you have to discipline
yourself you have to do that and it's
hard to shut off things so I actually
find I write best when I'm on the plane
like then playing right out here you
know there's no internet so you have to
do something and so it's like I find
those type of situations i write the
best and when I have actually
self-imposed deadline when I tell people
oh you know you're going to have the
script by March that then when I put
that out there it kind of forces me to
actually get get it done because if I
don't do any of that then again
you're right I'm you know I'm tweeting
facebooking things
it's like yeah hey it's a time sucker
you